"Mother-in-law" is an anagram of "Hitler woman".
It is forbidden for aircraft to fly over the
Taj Mahal.
A cat uses its whiskers to determine if a
space is too small to squeeze through.
There's a bookstore in Australia where books
are wrapped in paper with short descriptions
so no one can "judge a book by it's cover."
The U.S. spends more money per person on health
care than any other country, yet its life
expectancy is below average.
Mailing an entire building has been illegal
in the U.S. since 1916 when a man mailed a
40,000-ton brick house across Utah to avoid
high freight rates.
More than 1,000 different languages are spoken
on the continent of Africa.
Cats have over 100 vocal sounds; dogs only
have 10.
Two-thirds of the world's caviar is eaten
aboard the Queen Elizabeth 2 cruise ship.
Early draft names for Walt Disney's seven
dwarfs included Flabby, Dirty, Shifty, Lazy,
Burpy, Baldy and Biggo-Ego.
A shark is the only fish that can blink with
both eyes.
Certain frogs can be frozen solid then thawed,
and continue living.
Beauty pageants for children are banned in
France.
They are punishable with up to 2 years in
prison and a €30,000 fine.
Walt Disney was so poor in his twenties, he
had to eat dog food.
The smallest trees in the world are the dwarf
willows of Greenland.
They are two inches tall
Albanian has 27 words for different kinds
of moustache and 30 for eyebrows.